hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
this is the q a video for idea number 17
which was simply called
matter mostly we talked about the pali
exclusion principle and the spin
statistics theorem so
some combination of why two fermions
cannot live in the same quantum state
and also why that's related to the spin
of the fermions the fact that there's
spin one half or three half etc
and i think that for today's q a will be
pretty straightforward i'm not gonna try
to
load on a whole bunch of new heavy
concepts let's just go through some
questions
and answer them so to start there's a
very good one
what do you mean by matter anyway i
think i forget exactly
what i said but the point of the video
was to say that matter is
the stuff out of which you're made like
the physical tangible stuff
you the table the planet stuff like that
right so atoms electrons protons and
neutrons okay
but clearly that's supposed to be it
sounds like some technical
term that in this particular
circumstance reduces to those particular
things
but the point is actually no it's really
not a technical term in this
sense at all the philosophy behind this
is that you know back in the day as we
said in previous in the actual
matter video um we had this image that
maybe
you know 120 years ago we could have
thought that the world was made of some
combination of
particles like electrons protons and
neutrons even though they didn't know
that those were the particles back then
held together by forces and pushed
around by forces okay so there would be
a
separation into particles and forces and
uh roughly speaking particles were
particle-like obviously and forces were
wave-like
but then quantum mechanics came along
and blurred that distinction a little
bit
right the whole origin of quantum
mechanics was people discovering first
that waves had particle-like properties
that when you observe
photons when you observe light
sufficiently carefully
it comes in packets of energy which we
now call photons
and then of course particles have
wave-like properties that's why
electrons are not orbiting in little
solar system-like pictures in an atom
they're spread out over the wave
function
and so another leap forward of
unification came with quantum
field theory and now we say that
everything is made of fields so the
point is that
this old-fashioned dichotomy between
matter and forces isn't there
anymore it's just not an exact part of
nature so we say matter we're not
actually hiding some technical term that
we're not giving you the definition for
we're using it in an informal way
the distinction between fermions and
bosons particles that take up space
versus particles that like to climb on
top of each other
is scientifically accurate and rigorous
and we told you what that was it's the
wave function is symmetric or
anti-symmetric
but we just use matter in a very
colloquial way
and i get why that can be confusing so
one little sub question here
is mass in um
in the in the following sense sometimes
in very cold wheel speech
not among professional physicists but
just out there on the street
it's almost like matter and mass
are synonyms you know you talk about the
amount of matter
you have right and you can weigh it okay
and again this is something where you
have the old-fashioned terminology
and it gets adapted with slight changes
into the rigorous
scientific vocabulary so mass is
something perfectly well defined
mass is you can you can define the
following way take an object
what is its mass well put the object at
rest
and ask how much energy it has then e
equals m c squared so if you like
mass is the energy of an object at rest
divided by
c squared okay that's not the only way
to define it in the
newtonian limit you have f equals ma so
if you know you're exerting a force
on something then you can measure its
acceleration that's what the mass is the
inertial mass of something
but in this distinction between fermions
and bosons
there's no mapping on to that particular
idea that
mass is related to either fermions or
bosons but not
both there are certainly massless bosons
right there are long range forces the
photon of electromagnetism the graviton
of gravity
but there are also massive bosons
there's no problem with a boson
having mass even though in our informal
classification we didn't qualify it as
matter okay the w and z bosons the higgs
bosons etc
likewise fermions we called matter and
all the fermions that we know about in
the world are
massive they have at least a little bit
of mass but
the neutrinos have very very low masses
and it was believed for a long time
at least believed to be plausible the
neutrinos were exactly massless
there is no problem in principle with
having exactly massless
fermions either we just don't seem to
have those in the standard model
so there's no direct relationship
between the idea of mass
and the idea of matter that was just you
know speaking informally if anyone ever
confused those two things
the other uh confusion that comes up is
what about dark matter
right you've heard about dark matter
we'll talk about it later in another
video when we talk about cosmology
very very good reasons to believe that
dark matter is real
and i just did a video on matter which
was really about fermions
and the pallid exclusion principle and
the spin statistics theorem
does that imply that dark matter should
be made of fermions
and the answer is no this is just again
an unfortunate
sloppiness of nomenclature okay
dark matter so matter does have a
meaning to cosmologists
uh but the meaning is different you know
astronomers
this very happens very often astronomers
have a meaning to the word
metal right m-e-t-a-l what's a metal you
know you might
have the chemistry in mind and you might
think that there's some heavy elements
that are metallic and some that are not
to astronomers usually metals are
anything heavier than helium
uh sometimes anything have either
hydrogen it depends on what you mean but
basically most of the atoms in the world
are hydrogen and helium
so astronomers just say everything the
heavier than that is just a metal even
though you know neon or something like
that or carbon
uh not a very good metal so we adapt the
words to different circumstances
that give us information in the context
that we're using them so to a
cosmologist
cosmologists care about what is making
up the stuff of the universe
and so cosmologists say that matter
is anything that is moving velocity
much less than the speed of light that's
what it means
particles with velocities much less than
the speed of light and the contrast is
not with forces but with radiation
radiation is another thing that's very
important to the universe let's not make
this an equal sign let's make it narrow
the velocities equal the speed of light
so radiation
is anything and when i say the velocity
is equal to speed of light let's make
that
almost equal okay so as long as
something is moving at a substantial
fraction
of the speed of light it counts as
radiation and if it's moving slowly it
counts as
matter why is that because that affects
the cosmological
evolution if you think about the
expansion of the universe
let's draw it this way so here's the
universe space
and it's expanding over time right gets
bigger
and there's some particles and some
radiation in there okay so
there's some number of particles and
there's also some photons of radiation
maybe this is going this way this one's
going that way
and what happens is everything dilutes
as the universe gets bigger so then
let's let's say
for a little thought experiment here for
a situation that we're looking at
that particles and radiation are not
being created or destroyed okay so
neither matter particles nor photons or
anything are being produced or
annihilated
they're staying the same number as space
expands
then the number of particles stays the
same and the density of particles goes
down
because space gets bigger so for
matter to cosmologists
the total energy let's call it the
energy density
the energy density is usually written
rho and that is the
number density times the energy per
particle
okay so this is particles
per volume the number of particles per
cubic megaparsec or whatever
and this is the energy per particle
and if the particle is moving slower
than the speed of light
we're seeing we're thinking much slower
like it'd be really weird if particles
are moving at exactly
0.5 the speed of light there's a whole
bunch of room for the particles to be
moving very very close 99.9 percent of
the speed of light
and a whole bunch of room for them to be
moving at .001
the speed of light but it'd be weird if
they had the same order of magnitude so
we call those warm
matter particles but we don't really pay
much attention to them
there it's unlikely that we hit that
sweet spot exactly but
the energy is mass times the speed of
light squared right so this is just
the number density of particles times
the mass times the speed of light
squared
and what happens is the mass and the
speed of light just stay the same
so as space expands um
we talk about the scale factor
[Music]
and let's call it a don't ask me why
it's called a
you might say well should we call it r
for distance or something like that but
there's so many r's all there
already in general relativity with the
riemann tensor and the richie tensor and
everything it's easier just to call the
scale factor a
so it's going up right so this energy
density
as a goes up the energy density goes
down because space gets bigger the
number
of particles stays the same and this is
proportional oops
what happened there oh my goodness go
away
yeah this is proportional to a
to the minus three because the linear
size is
a the volume is a cubed the density goes
down as the volume goes up okay
and that's what is important for
cosmology so let me shrink this a little
bit
what's important for cosmology is how
the energy density
changes as a function of the scale
factor because that's going to go into
helping you
understand how fast the universe is
expanding and how that expansion rate is
changing over time
whereas for radiation
the energy density oops rho is
again it's still the number density
times the energy per particle
and the number density goes uh let's
just call it end still but e what is the
energy per particle well
um you have these photons but they're
being redshifted
right their wavelengths are being
stretched with the expansion of the
universe
okay so the energy of the particle
e radiation uh equals
h planck's constant times the frequency
and the frequency goes down as the
wavelength
goes up right as you stretch the
wavelength it vibrates less and less
frequency
frequently as it passes you by so this
is proportional to one over the scale
factor
okay so n times e is
n times h times the frequency and that
is proportional to well
n the number density goes down like a
cubed
and f the frequency goes down like a so
this is proportional to 1 over a to the
fourth
as opposed to this let's just put in
similar notation here
1 over a cubed so this is what
cosmologists care about cosmologists
care about
not whether something is solid because
you know none of these dark matter
particles are making up chairs and
tables or even planets probably
they're just particles out there all by
themselves what cosmologists care about
are the particles moving close to the
speed of light because if they're moving
close to the speed of light
their energy density fades away faster
as space expands so matter goes as a to
the minus three
radiation goes as a to the minus four so
what does this have to do with
bosons and fermions nothing at all
absolutely zero so cosmologists talk
about dark matter
they do not mean even a little bit that
the dark matter is supposed to be
fermions because they don't mean matter
in the sense of solid
matter that you can put a coffee cup on
okay they just don't care about that
so if you look at the list of dark
matter candidates you have the weakly
interacting massive particles
right those are typically fermions it
just works out that way again there's no
special benefit
posons or fermions but it works out that
in supersymmetric models the easiest
candidates for
stable dark matter particles are
fermions
but the second most common candidate uh
popular candidate let's say
for dark matter are the axions and the
axions are bosons
they're little scalar bosons uh so
there's no connection
between the cosmologists use of the word
matter and whether something is a boson
or fermion long story short
what matters is they're not moving close
to the speed of light i should mention
here
i i said you know photons redshift
okay uh and that makes sense because you
think of the photon as really a wave no
matter how
much i tell you it looks like a particle
um
but the same relationship between
the scale factor and the energy of a
particle is true for any particle that
moves
close to the speed of light so even if
you're not literally a photon
you would still lose momentum as the
universe expands
if you're moving close to the speed of
light once you're much slower than the
speed of light then who cares your
energy is coming from m c
squared not from your velocity okay but
the velocity changes
if you move closer to the speed of light
in an important way
so this radiation does not simply mean
electromagnetic radiation it would be
just as true for
gravitational radiation even though the
energy density that is expected to be
very low
it would be also true if you had some
other kind of particles like if
neutrinos
really were massless then they would act
like
radiation they're not they're massive
so once so the neutrinos have a regime
in which they do move close to the speed
of light
uh roughly speaking if the v well the
velocities are high enough they move
close to the speed of light and then
they would redshift away
like radiation and that's very important
cosmologists take that into
consideration
if the universe expands so much that the
neutrinos start moving
slowly compared to the speed of light
then suddenly they act like matter and
that depends on what the masses
of the neutrinos are okay more cosmology
than you really need to know there but
again
different uses of the word matter in
different contexts
okay here's a harder question
the pauli exclusion principle versus e
m and what i mean here is uh
for stability of matter when you make a
table
uh or a chair or whatever when you push
those atoms close together
is the reason why the atoms do take up
space is it really ultimately because of
the pali exclusion principle
or is it because of the electromagnetic
repulsion of the particles of the
electrons and the protons and so forth
the answer is uh it really is mostly
because of the pali exclusion principle
but it's complicated and you can tell
it's going to be complicated if you
think of you know two atoms you try to
put them on top of each other
strictly speaking what the pali
exclusion principle says
is you can't put the electrons of those
atoms into exactly the same quantum
state
it doesn't strictly speaking say you
can't put them really really close to
each other
in the quantum state right but it turns
out you can't i mean it turns out that
there is
some force effectively pushing particles
away from quantum states that other
fermions are already
in and that's fermi worked out uh this
whole story
but you know not very convincingly
because it's complicated so people have
continued to think about it uh if you
want to look up
a fairly modern work on this elliott
lieb
is a guy shouldn't write and talk
elliot lieb has written some papers on
the stability of matter and explaining
it's really because of the pelvic
exclusion principle
mostly and you can sort of i mean that
does make sense right
certainly the sizes of atoms are set by
the palady exclusion principle
right the you're trying to put electrons
into energy levels you can't all squeeze
them down so they have to have a big
more extended uh
energy level so they're bigger when you
have more electrons in there
um if it turns out if electrons were
bosons then matter would not just not be
stable all the atoms would just pile
right on top of each other
electromagnetism however does play an
important role
in the precise way in which atoms and
molecules come together so it's not
just the paladi exclusion principle
until you get down to like a neutron
star or white dwarf densities for
ordinary tables and chairs
electromagnetism matters
a lot but still pally's solution
principle matters even more
for figuring out the size and the
stability of matter so
i have to sort of say trust me on that
one or read these papers those are your
two choices i can't really give you a
convincing casual explanation of that
okay here's a here's a good question
which you know i probably should have
answered long ago you know spin we talk
about
the spin of let's say an electron spin
up or spin down because it's been one
half particle
the two possible measurement outcomes
you get are separated by h-bar so that's
separated by one so you either get plus
or minus
one-half why is
it though that when you actually put the
electron
through let's say the stern gerlock
experiment okay here's our very
simplified stern gerlock experiment
here's an electron
goes through a magnetic field and it
either goes up
or down spin up or spin down
and the point of this was it's never in
between
okay no matter what the original spin of
the electron was you might imagine that
the spin of the electron was
perpendicular to the magnetic field then
it would go right on through
right it would not be going up or down
at all
why is it that it goes discreetly into
those two possibilities of either spin
up or spin down
someone someone said very very uh
i forget who who put it into the
questions but this is very perceptive
comment
um when we talk about electrons
in atoms and the fact that they have
discrete energy levels
or when we talk about particles in
quantum field theory
in both cases we start with something
which is very very wavy
and the discreteness only comes about
because of boundary conditions when we
solve the equations that these waves
are satisfying so here we have some
discreteness
spin up or spin down where does that
come from that doesn't sound like
something that starts off as wavy
uh it is and that's true it's a slightly
different explanation here
um let's imagine that you did have spin
right so let's say
the spin we're gonna write down the spin
wave function of the electron okay uh
let's imagine that it's pointing in the
x direction so we're imagining little uh
axes here x y z
and the magnetic field is pointing in
the z direction
okay so let's imagine we've set up the
electron to be spinning in the x
direction so perpendicular to the
magnetic field
what's going to happen well if you go
all the way back to our discussion of
the uncertainty principle etc
we talked about the fact that an
electron with a spin in the x
direction can be written it's not
changing anything it's exactly the same
thing
as 1 over the square root of 2 an
electron pointing in the plus
z direction plus an electron pointing in
the minus
z direction in other words spin right
if this is the axis pointing right is a
superposition
can be thought of as a superposition of
spin up and spin down this is part of
the
spin version of the heisenberg
uncertainty principle
so this is these this is truly
inequality this is just two different
ways of
writing down exactly the same thing so
and this is this would not be there's no
classical analog of this okay this is
true quantum mechanics coming
at you here so when you say you have a
particle whose spin is perpendicular to
the
uh magnetic field it's going to pass
through that is the same as saying
you have a superposition of a particle
that's been plus
along the magnetic field and a particle
spin minus along the magnetic field okay
and then it turns out that in order to
ask what you actually
observe you have to go through the
schrodinger equation you have to go say
what's the hamiltonian how does this
magnetic field interact
with the spin that is passing through it
and the answer is
in this case with the magnetic field
pointing the z direction the magnetic
field
interacts with these two components
separately in completely independent
ways it does not interact directly
with what you would call the x-direction
of the spin
it feels and acts on these two
parts of the spin wave function the plus
z part and the minus z part
it sends the plus z part up like this
it sends the minus z part down like that
if you
rotated the magnetic field so the
magnetic field are pointing in the x
direction
then it would interact with this x part
of the magnetic field
it would interact with the x uh way of
saying
a way of writing down what the magnetic
field what the electron's spin field was
so it's not a spin field the electrons
spin was
so that's the best i can do to explain
why you get these two discrete things
it's because from the point of view of
the magnetic field
which is pointing in the z direction and
interacting with the electron in a very
specific way
the right way to think about the
electron is as a superposition of spin
up and spin down that's what it is it's
not
spin left spin right it's been different
directions the interaction with the
magnetic field
sets the right way to write down what
the electron spin is actually doing
and that's why it goes into spin up and
spin down
so i started writing the question why
discrete spin
observations why are discrete spins
observed
that's why hopefully that's successful
uh as an explanation
related question um how many
spins can be observed
spin states spin answers how many
answers can you get to the question what
is the spin of this particle
uh well for spin one half
indeed as we just said you can get two
you can get up and down
but then what about spin one so let's
say you sent
um a photon or a w boson through
this kind of experiment what would it do
so it turns out
that once you go beyond spin one half
the right thing to say
is for any particle of any spin the
number of
possible spin states you can observe
now let's just erase it the number of
possible spin states you can observe the
answer is
two times the spin plus one okay so if
it's spin one half particle
uh two times a half is one plus one is
two it's a spin one particle two times
one is two plus one is three
if it's a spin three halves particle
it would be four spin two particle
five etc okay so
if you had a w boson for example which
has spin one and you send it through the
stern girl lock experiment you have to
do it very very quickly because w bosons
decay
very rapidly but in principle you would
get three different possible answers
spin up plus one spin down minus one and
spin zero there's a spin zero component
of the w boson ate the higgs boson
remember
it got a spin zero component that way
except that
if a particle is massless then it's
always moving at the speed of light
and the particles that move with the
speed of light there's only two ways for
the spin to be the spin can either be
lined along
the direction of motion or against the
direction of motion
notice that this only makes sense for
particles that are moving at the speed
of light if the particle is moving
slower than the speed of light
you can always go into its rest frame
where it's not moving at all or you can
just go into a frame where it's moving
the opposite direction
but if particles moving at the speed of
light in some direction then everyone
agrees
that particle's moving at the speed of
light in that direction and in that case
there's only
spin along the direction of motion or
spin against the direction of motion
so for massless particles
they have what is called helicity
and the helicity is just the amount of
spin in the direction
of the particle motion and there's only
two values plus or minus
but they'd be separated by a bigger
number if the spin of the original
particle were
bigger so remember for a spin two
particle for example which has five
fundamental
in principle spin components they would
be
spin two particle is plus two plus one
zero minus one minus two so if it's a
massless spin two particle the graviton
it's plus two along the direction of
motion or minus two along the direction
of motion
but in principle otherwise if you
somehow had a weird theory with a
massive spin to particle there would be
five possible
spin states you would get and they would
all be discrete and they all would be
observable in the stern gerlach
experiment
there's one other caveat here the actual
stern gerlock experiment
stern gerlock experiment
it's making use of the fact that the
electron is electrically charged
so it's both spinning and it's
electrically charged
it's like a little magnet it's like the
earth with its magnetic field and so it
can
be spinning up or spinning down and it's
that magnetic field of the electron that
is actually coupling
to this magnetic field that is passing
through so in principle you could have a
neutral spinning particle that just
wouldn't be deflected by the magnetic
field at all
in practice you know there are things
called finemen diagrams and virtual
particles
so in practice even neutral particles
have this cloud of virtual particles
around them which have some
electrically charged particles in them
so they can still have what is called a
magnetic moment
and they might still be able to be
deflected and it's during gerlock
experiment but it'd be a very very very
tiny
amount of deflection okay
uh good there's another question
it's not you know as usual it's not
exactly the question that's asked i
interpret it in my own way why
are gage bosons
spin one and the graviton
spin two i'm not going to answer this
question
very very effectively but i'll chat
about it just a little bit
um someone i think the literal question
that someone asked was is it just a
coincidence that photons and w bosons
are both spin one
no it's not a coincidence and gluons are
also spin one
gauge bosons are spin one
and here's that hand wavy way that i
will uh talk about it
remember that these gauge bosons
the field from which they come is the
connection field
okay for some gauge symmetry you thought
you were past that didn't you you
thought you wouldn't need to think about
this anymore but this is exactly what it
is
the connection is the way that if i have
some path
between two points and i have a vector
uh the connection tells me how to
parallel transport that vector along the
path right remember that
if my vector is for an internal symmetry
right like red green blue okay then
the connection looks like a
mu a
b where if i write let's see if i can
write this correctly so this is a vector
v a 1
and v a 2. so the components of this
vector
get the letter a and the letter a
in this case is an index that runs over
let's say red
green or blue if it's a quark right it's
in color space this is a vector in color
space
it's not a vector in real space that has
an index x y
z it's a vector in color space that has
it so we give it a different
uh alphabet the roman alphabet or we use
different letters let's put it that way
we're only trying to use the roman
alphabet here
but uh a instead of i j k which we might
use for x y and z
we use letters like a b and c for color
space indices okay
so red green and blue the different
quark colors
do not have any relationship with
directions in space
okay with directions in physical space
up down left right forward backward
so mu here is a
space time index
and it's telling you how you're moving
in space time
along this path right that's what it's
there for whereas these indices
are internal indices
color indices in the case of quark
fields okay
so this is the kind of field you need
to have a gauge symmetry in an internal
space
and the point is there is one space-time
index
and the fact that there's one space-time
index means that as far as
space-time is concerned this is a vector
okay and vectors are things that when
you rotate them around by 360 degrees
they come back to where you started
that's why vectors are spin one so this
would be a spin-one particle
and that's why gauge bosons are spin one
it's a very hand-wavy explanation but
the essential truth is actually there
okay
whereas remember that gravity can be
thought of as a gauge theory but it's a
weird gauge theory it's not
doesn't work the same way that the other
gauge theories do
uh and one of the reasons why it's weird
is because you don't have any internal
degrees of freedom
for gravity everything is just time okay
it's space time that is uh the direction
in which you move
and the direction which a vector that
you parallel transport
in would be okay and that further has
there's an extra complication that in
fact you derive the connection
from the metric in gravity you don't
start with the connection usually
most typical in the way that einstein
would have done it let's put it that way
you derive the connection from
the metric and the metric remember
is a tensor which looks like a little
matrix in space time
g mu nu so that's a four by four matrix
and again
there are two indices now that run over
time
and space t x y z the four dimensions of
space time
and you usually as we said very briefly
last time you write this
as uh the minkowski metric eta
you knew plus a little perturbation and
we call that h
mu nu so h mu nu
is the field whose tiny fluctuations
give rise to the graviton
and guess what it has two indices not
just one it has
two space-time indices so you're going
to take my word for it but
that means it becomes spin tube
to get the actual answer there you have
to talk about things like we talked
about before you know how do particles
respond
to the fluctuations in this metric
tensor passing by
gravitational waves rotation by 90
degrees all that stuff the different
polarizations
of the gravitational waves um but there
are but none of this is a coincidence or
an accident is the real point here there
are reasons why
the different gauge bosons have the
different spins that they do
this is sort of a half-baked way of
explaining what those reasons are but
nevertheless the reasons are there
that's the more important thing
um a couple more little questions this
one was kind of fun
so i you know i liked it i had to think
about it actually myself
we talked about the fact that when you
interchange two particles
uh when you interchange the wave
function x1
x2 we said that either you got
plus psi x1
x2 in other words it stayed the same
or you got minus psi
x1 x2 and we call these bosons
we call these fermions and
the argument was that well if you
interchange and then interchange again
you better get back to where you started
right so if you multiplied by some other
number
other than plus one or minus one that
wouldn't happen so these are the two
options
so some clever person said well why not
psi goes to the complex conjugate
of psi that is another operation
which when you do it twice when you
complex conjugate twice you go back
complex conjugate twice you go back to
where you started
the reason why this doesn't work is
because that well the technical reason
the highbrow reason is
complex conjugation is a transformation
that is not
smoothly connected to the identity it is
a discrete
transformation once and for all it's
like a reflection in complex
space so if you think about complex
plane
here's the real part of psi
and here's the imaginary part of psi
complex conjugation takes a point here
and just moves it
all the way down to a point right down
there okay
it flips across the axis every every
point over here
is brought down to its reflection point
on the other side of the real axis
and so it is absolutely true that if you
do this twice you get back to where you
started
but what's also true is that you can't
do it just a little bit
right when we talked about this
interchange operation
sure what we care about is the answer
when you get all the way over
to having interchanged both of them but
it needs
for it really to be an interchange of
the two particles something has to
happen
along the way there is a wave function
corresponding to having moved the
particles a little bit and then a little
bit more and then a little bit more
what we're telling you is what the wave
function is once you get
to exactly the two particles
interchanged but something has to happen
to it along the way
that's why what matters is that there
needs to be a way to smoothly connect
that transformation to the identity it
can't be a simple on or off
kind of thing so there would be some
other transformation
of psi in the real world case for bosons
or fermions
when you move the particles just a
little bit and it's generally
complicated and i'm not going to write
it down but what we know is that when
you move them all the way
it either picks up a plus one or a minus
one
okay final question um
which i think you know i said something
about this in the lecture in the
video but uh maybe i can be more clear
um how again i'm saying this in my own
language
how do white dwarfs
become neutron stars
neutron stars become black holes
both of things which we think happen and
create giant explosions when they do
happen
um the point being that in that white
dwarfs and neutron stars
um really are degenerate stars by
degenerate in this case we don't mean
they're perverted
we mean that they have uh all of the
electrons or all the particles that make
them up are packed as closely as they
can possibly
be the thing keeping a white dwarf from
collapsing or neutron star from
collapsing
is absolutely the paladin exclusion
principle okay you just
can't squeeze the fermions more densely
than that
and so the reason why white dwarfs white
dwarfs are bigger
than neutron stars and that's because
they're made of protons and neutrons and
electrons
protons neutrons electrons neutron stars
are just made of neutrons
okay and for the white dwarfs protons
and neutrons don't really matter
because remember electrons have a longer
compton wavelength because their mass is
lower
and therefore when you pack them close
together they take up more space
so any one electron has a bigger volume
than a proton or a neutron does
at its degeneracy pressure limit that
when it's packed as closely as it can
possibly be
so who cares about the protons and
neutrons for white dwarfs i mean they're
there
they give you the mass of the white
dwarf but the density
is fixed by the electrons whereas the
density of the neutron star
is fixed by neutrons so it's way more
dense
because neutrons are much smaller and
their compton wavelengths are much
smaller so you can fit them
closer to each other so the question was
i think the the spirit of the question
was
well if you start with a white dwarf um
how can you ever pack it closely enough
to make it into a neutron star
like the electron like you just said the
electrons are packed as closely as they
possibly can be
or likewise maybe a clearer way of
asking the question is for a neutron
star
since neutrons are heavier and
there's nowhere for them to go how can
they ever even collapse
into a black hole um
so for the white dwarfs collapsing to
neutron stars you know this was
uh the work that made chandrasekhar
famous
the chandrasekhar limit uh it and it's
it's it involves complicated
physics because it's not just general
relativity it's also the nuclear and
particle physics that's going on
and what happens is because of quantum
mechanics when you have all these
electrons
tightly packed but there are also
electron uh protons and neutrons there
there is a probability just like there's
a probability we have a neutron
all by itself there's a probability
we'll decay
into a proton an electron and a neutrino
when you have a proton a neutron and an
electron
there's a probability that the proton
and the electron come together to make a
neutron
and an and a neutrino so so neutron
decay
looks like this neutron
goes to proton plus electron plus
anti-neutrino
but what what to call this
i don't know what to call it but you
know neutron star creation
starts from proton plus electron
goes to neutron plus what do you think
it has to be this is my
little homework assignment for you i
mean you know electric charge has to be
conserved but the electric charge on the
left proton plus electron is zero
so you need a neutral particle and
you know that baryon number has to be
conserved so there's barrier number one
on the left already bearing number one
on the right
so you need baryon number zero and
lepton number is conserved you have
lepton number one on the left so you
need a lepton on the right
and in fact the electron is going to be
electronis
is going to be approximately conserved
here so it's the not the anti-neutrino
but the electron neutrino that is uh
created and this is why when you get a
supernova explosion when a white dwarf
collapses to make a neutron star
uh it's a prime target for detecting
neutrinos in the universe right
supernova 1987a
was detected in neutrinos there's like
13 neutrinos that were detected here
uh many light years away from the actual
supernova because it gives off
all these neutrinos so this is an
unlikely
event right this is slow this is not
probable but if you have a whole
starfall
occasionally it will happen and when it
happens it likes to stay that way
because it's smaller the whole thing
wants to get smaller and so is that
there what chandrasekhar showed is there
is a point of no return a point where it
is so dense that this star's happening
rapidly
and then you get this supernova
explosion for the neutron stars going to
black holes it's a trickier
situation it's more a pure general
relativity
statement um it's it's the
neutrons really have nowhere to go okay
i mean it's not
i can't say that maybe they have
somewhere to go
but there's very little room because you
can prove just on the basis of general
relativity
that if whatever matter you have that
makes up your star
is relatively normal like it's a
positive energy positive pressure
things like that the pressure is not
greater than the energy density
there's a whole bunch of things you can
put on without going into the details of
the nuclear physics
you can show that if you make things
dense enough they have to keep
collapsing
it's just gravity always wins in that
case
so what has to happen somehow is that
the quantum wave function of the stuff
that is making up the neutrons
converts into something else which is
not violating the pali exclusion
principle so the question
being asked was is are the rules of
quantum mechanics
somehow being violated uh the answer is
no
the rules of quantum mechanics are not
being violated the palette exclusion
principle is not put on hold
temporarily or anything like that uh but
we can get this conclusion that neutron
stars will collapse if they become
sufficiently dense
purely from general relativity and
quantum mechanics is going to have to
adapt
quantum mechanics is going to have to
allow the wave function for the neutrons
to turn into something that can have
energy packed into a smaller
region and the details of how that
happens are not clear they're certainly
not clear to me there are people who
study them and know a lot more than i do
if you've ever heard of the concept of
strange stars or
charmed stars it comes from the idea
that possibly
uh you could trade in you know a neutron
is uh an up quark and two downs
so you could create a strange baryon
with up down and a strange quark
remember strange quark is heavier
than the ups or the downs so this
particle
in real the real world would just decay
away very very quickly
but uh if it's packed densely enough
it's more
massive than the neutron is so maybe you
could convert over to particles with
strange quarks in them in fact maybe you
can convert all of the up and down
quarks into strange quarks and then you
could squeeze them more tightly
i don't know what the state of the art
is about whether these things actually
exist remember
there's the there's the size of a real
neutron star
and there's a proof that you can do in
general relativity that nothing can be
this dense or more and there's a little
bit of room in between
the actual density of neutron stars and
the maximum limit you get from general
relativity
so there might be room for stars that
are
more compact than neutron stars but
still made of quarks and not forming
black holes
that's something that uh again we don't
i don't think we know about it there are
people i'm not sure how it depends on
what your feelings are about the laws of
physics like
in the standard model of particle
physics maybe people know or maybe
people are pretty confident
but maybe there are slight variations in
the standard model of particle business
so people talk about quark stars
and things like that as far as i know
that's still an open question
that's a good place to end the q a video
because you need to be reminded
occasionally there's plenty of questions
i don't know the answer to
that's one of them i'm sure you'll
continue to find more and more